language seems to mean nothing these
days and what do I know I'm not a
biologist here to discuss this and more
I have Alex Stein host of prime time
with Alex Stein here on blazetv and
their first time on the program we've
got Royce Lopez and uh he just goes by
Marsh
but merch is how they know how they know
him and they are the hosts of the
Revenge of the CIS podcast we're happy
to have you guys here and I want to say
this I have to cut off the program gosh
we agree with everything the CDC says we
love Dr fauci and the vaccine is the
most safe and effective drug ever
created sorry go ahead well I so I I
could hear all of you guys audibly
reacting yeah absurdity that's a Korean
Jean-Pierre just said so I want to give
you guys a chance to uh share your
thoughts Alex you wanted I mean I think
I mean I'll just start off with it it's
they can't even put a number on it I
mean like you said there's so many laws
you can't get a tattoo you can't join
the military you can't it's basic
numbers just put a number but they don't
want to put a number on it right she
just gave the longest non-answer I've
ever heard so I mean it's just an
indication that there's they want more
trans kids and they want to create
legislation that gets more access for
youth to have gender reassignment or
hormone therapy I think it's pretty
obvious that's their stance yeah rice I
love that they they retconned everything
into anything that's pro-trans
if they go with this Pro how come
everything Pro trans is anti-kid like
it's it's the same like pro-choice
pro-life thing you're messing with words
no it's really simple when I grew up
there was always people that were trans
I remember them and we laughed at them
because it's just funny and I don't care
Monty Python people in the wigs it's
funny but that's fine but we had an
understanding like look I don't care
just leave me alone but now it's like
when you press secretaries shouldn't be
talking about people changing their sex
in any circumstance like it's Martin
Luther King or the Civil Rights yeah
right they really are trying to make
this the new civil rights right but the
point is the Civil Rights had an end
where it was like okay this is where we
want one equality the problem with the
transfer but in a lot of movements like
this now once they become monetized
there's no need to end it because then
then the cash flow stops you can't buy
14 million dollar Mansions or B Dylan
Mulvaney and be in the White House you
know yeah
um it is fascinating too because when
you ask them you ask them like what
rights are you seeking that you don't
already have they never seem to have an
answer for that yeah well it's the right
to groom kids let's be honest the Civil
Rights Movement took a huge leap from
you know hey why don't you let black
people own houses to uh let us mutilate
your child and teach them sex so but I
think you know I'm not trying to be a
contrarian here I think you guys being a
little tough on kjp she does have a good
point in that trans people are brave
because there's nothing braver than
mutilating your entire body for a
dopamine rush and 15 minutes of fame and
Tick Tock followers and Tick Tock that's
pretty brave I wouldn't do it you know
it's just like I wouldn't join the
Marines and I probably would never you
know cut things off of me either so I
don't know man it's pretty brave okay so
when you don't have breasts you don't
need a sports bra
and when you don't have breasts I feel
like you probably are not a good
representation to sell sports bras to
women well here's something that we talk
we've talked about our show a bunch of
times with Dylan is specifically the
weirdest thing normally when people
transition the first thing they get done
is the boobs because it's the easiest
one just this easiest one but with him
for whatever reason he went and he got
the bottom surgery but first and then he
went and he shaved down his jaw like it
was a piece of Parmesan cheese and he's
like no I'm a girl and but he hasn't
done he hasn't done the boobs yet and at
first we've been racking our brains like
it doesn't make any sense unless the
reason is you want to look like a 12
year old girl which is what that's a
good because it's it's not my journey
into Womanhood it's my journey into girl
which is weird yeah it is yeah we just
talked about that that verbiage the
other day and how weird it was because
you see the other videos of him
um like with little girl like material
little Louise or whatever yeah I mean it
is very weird
um but one thing that he also has not
done one I might add is I he clearly is
not taking hormones I don't I I would be
shocked if he was taking estrogen I want
to play I'm going to play a video of him
reacting to like oh I haven't been on
social media lately because it was just
been going through a lot with all of the
reactions to my Partnerships but um in
that video you'll notice when he tips
his head up I'm like that is a beard
that is a beard so how it's so weird all
right let's watch that Hi how are you I
haven't been making as many videos
there's been a lot going on right and I
was feeling a little down but I was
walking on the sidewalk in New York
and this garbage truck Drives By Me and
the garbage man leans out of the truck
and goes hello Dylan
hello
it was the most unexpected person and it
gave me the courage to keep going and um
I love you and if you're that man that's
watching us right now you really made my
day and I especially love you okay
well I have to say this isn't don't
little kids love the garbage truck and
garbage man too isn't that like a little
kid thing probably yeah I'm just saying
I feel like they like big trucks there's
I mean that is very nice you're really
into trains sometimes I'm saying kids
are like but but it's the the five
o'clock by the way I I I
um
I did see uh who was uh what's her uh
what's her name from the simcast she had
a really funny joke Chrissy mad this
really funny joke about the Bud Light
thing it killed me she posted the him uh
dealing with the Bud Light and it says
it's five five o'clock shadow somewhere
and that killed me and I've seen other
photos of villanovania before where it's
like coming all in and you're like yeah
did you see his price was right did you
see yes that was wild because it's like
you've always wanted attention and it's
just how far would you go like back in
the day when we were younger people like
there's a lizard guy that would split
his tongue in half and put the black in
his eyes and it's like oh there's a
freak and you're like this is just a new
form of that but the difference is I
used to be able to make fun of that guy
I now get arrested in certain States if
I do the same thing and it's like look
you do whatever you want but you have a
five o'clock by the way I said that was
a made-up story that didn't happen that
never happened there was no garbage man
that's okay that's what I'm gonna act
like I don't think it happened either so
like the in case you're one of the
people that watches me I don't think a
New York city garbage man is like
finally home after a tough day I'm gonna
watch Dylan Moby
after a long they have thrown garbage
out I go watch the view to watch Drew
Barrymore get in our knees and go this
dildo Mulvaney dude I've turned it
around because now the problem is I go
you know what this is great men are
winning again men are on top again and
this is
patriarchy Libra white women
literally carried the flag for this it's
like leave them alone and now you're
getting blown out in sports and I'm
laughing going like you're doing this to
yourself yeah you broke the glass
ceiling and then shoved the shards in
your eyes I'm like why are you doing
this so it's it's kind of you called us
bigots for years when we were going you
don't want this and they're like no
we're fighting for their okay but you're
I'm telling you you're going to regret
this yeah no what do I know yeah I so
okay so that I want to ask you there's
the latest controversy is Jack Daniels
now because Jack Daniels so I want to be
clear this was a marketing campaign from
Jack Daniels that resurfaced so it was
done in 2021 during pride month
um but this is drag queens partnering
with Jack Daniels here's part of that ad
watch so my question is why
yes but also I when we go out I don't
like I order a Jack and diet right yeah
do they get a pass because this was done
in 2021 or and but I I still feel like
they were kind of groomy in 20 years
none of them can pass let's go let's
start with that so but they're not
passing right right right but no I I
feel like they this is so gross and now
I'm like God do I need to stop drinking
Jack Daniels I said this today so then
over to the dark side start drinking
Irish whiskey I know that's that's the
way to go I mean I will do they do they
promote do they promote this oh no no
they're super misogynistic I love it I'm
in they're like super no but the problem
is the thing with boycotts is I mean in
theory it sounds great but the reality
is here's what's going to happen
someone's gonna walk into a bar and be
like can I have a Bud Light can I have a
middle light no we only have Bud Light
all right that's fine yeah that's the
real world and I I know I'm not saying
people you know support what you want
but the reality is just like we say to
the left it's the truth the Twitter's
not the real world people are going to
go out listen oh I'm not gonna have a
Budweiser order one of the other 50
beers they own because that's the
problem that's the other issue when
three companies run the world you can't
boycott everything like somebody said it
today on Twitter it's like if Monsanto
just decided to to go super wook you're
not gonna eat bread yeah right and and
that's the real problem the real problem
is what boycotting the real problem is
why do we let it get this we got real
bad real quick when everyone controls if
we all thought free market free market
which is great but then when now it's
just the government's working with all
the free market and there's no free
market anymore it's like you're doing
this you're not gonna have a bank and
that's it free market doesn't work when
like seven companies own everything now
right yeah that's not really free market
actually yeah uh Donald so this is wild
to me guys Donald Trump speaking from we
covered the the speech of course
speaking from Mar-A-Lago on Tuesday uh
the first time since he had been
arrested
and ABC News in their broadcast blurred
out his Podium that said to text Trump
like to to get official campaign
notifications they blurred out the text
number so that you couldn't text and
find out more watch I never thought
anything like this could happen in
America never thought it could happen
this is the wildest thing I've ever seen
are they doing it on purpose because
either these people are stupid which is
possible or I don't know what's
happening because the first thing you
just gave it more exposure to always do
this all the time because now people I
know that most people probably ignore
that but now people that were watching
are like what was why would they go on
Twitter it's trending yeah and then more
people are going to give money so it's
like why are you doing this I think it's
because they need Trump to be to be in
there because I think that they already
Trump's the villain right he's a super
villain to them so they need the guy
that they've already built entire
dossiers and everything against was like
that's the only reason because I don't
understand nothing they're doing he's
just going to be photoshopped on like
another rap album for a chance to think
it's funny and he's gonna win again well
I mean there is an alternative they
could just be that stupid that's what I
said they could also just yeah I think I
do think that they could just be that
stupid and just for for clarification
for um just to set the record straight
this was Joe Biden's Podium broadcast by
ABC uh in 2020 where you can clearly see
see his text message yeah there it is
but if you text that you just signed you
up to Ben and Jerry's flavor of the
month club
right though people are just going to
get curious now most Americans are just
going to see blurred out thing and be
like I bet there's boobs under there
yeah
literally they're like
cool yeah
um so I want to switch over to uh RFK so
Robert F Kennedy Jr
um is has filed to run for president as
a Democrat
um now I'm interested to hear your
thoughts on this because I have seen a
lot of conservatives very interested in
this because of his position on medical
freedom and because medical Freedom has
been something that I think a lot of
conservatives have really reconsidered
since covid
um it's kind of I always said the silver
lining of kovid will be that people will
be awoken to the medical industrial
complex as Alex calls it and big Pharma
and I think that that happened
um but I am a little concerned that that
is going to siphon off some Republican
votes because I mean I don't think that
Democrats are not going to vote for him
they hate him they think he's an
anti-vaxxer and they can't stand the guy
so I'm interested to see how this plays
out well the enemy of my enemy is my
friend so if you look at the mainstream
media as portraying Robert Kennedy as an
anti-vaxxer and just as a conspiracy
theorist so that makes me like him more
so I don't know if he's going to get my
vote but I definitely he has my support
on uh you know his side I hope he causes
some chaos there without causing chaos
on our side yeah me too I don't think
he'll take votes away because because
look he's he's not going to get the
nomination yeah I know I don't think
that's something to worry about but I
think in terms of the positive the
positive stuff with somebody like that
is it makes a lot of people Democrats
and Republicans answer a lot of
uncomfortable questions about the
medical stuff yeah because like you know
one I think one of I think if most
people would agree that one of Trump's
biggest weak spots was it's still his
stance on the vaccine and that to me is
is something where it's it's hard to
defend that and somebody coming in
they're going like yeah but you know
what
the vaccine is terrible you know so so
into Freedom might do that that's the
biggest most uncomfortable thing he's
not going to get it because he was
painted he was painted crazy so long ago
right that you know and I think he's
dead right about a lot yes yes I love it
it's uncomfortable to people how right
he is because I have I always said I
apologize to people because you know
when I was younger I would be laugh at
people that wouldn't get their kids
vaccinated but then I said like I was
stupid it's like obviously no wonder now
I know what this feels like this feels
like wait a second what are they putting
into you and I think I think the best
thing and it's safe and effective safe
and effective and even from when I was a
kid the number of vaccines I got so the
number of kids again now is ridiculous
and that's a real thing you know I'm not
saying don't get the polio vaccine
obviously but what I am saying is
the fact that this that this vaccine
wasn't able to be questioned in the fact
that this guy's running on it I like
anything that gets more Spotlight
regardless of what party they're on on
the medical like you said the medical
industrial complex that to me is more
important than anything else yeah yeah I
just want to see him at the debates but
like he's not like he said he's not
gonna get he's not gonna win we'll get
the nomination but I just want to see
him on National Television being like
yeah they killed you with this facts
like they pretty much just ruined no
that's the entire generation of people
we want to just make this very
abundantly clear we love the vaccine and
listen if I got three polio vaccines and
I got polio three times I would get a
fourth polio vaccine that's how vaccines
work so we love it thank you Dr fauci I
do I do I do I just will be very
interested to see you know I mean in the
primaries right like you can only if
you're only voting in one right I just
don't want Republicans to vote to decide
to vote in the Democrat primary just to
try to get Kennedy to be the guy because
he's not going to be the guy and all
that will do is water down the rest of
the votes in the Republican primary yeah
I mean they're perfect it's going to be
either desans it's going to be Trump
that's about I mean Trump is like
especially after this they they shot him
up yeah you know so even even if that
does happen I don't really think it'll
affect if the general election will
affect anything it's going to be one or
two people basically and I think if
you're if you're on a republic if you're
a Republican and you seems to be people
that are more for the medical Freedom
now more DeSantis people so there is
kind of an option obviously not as
hardcore as so what if K is right that
guys but but still you know so I think
that I'm not too worried about that I
just think he it's the point of this for
get him on TV and to talk about this and
have people make people listen to it
yeah no I totally agree people actually
vote in the Democratic primary anymore
after 2016. I just I wouldn't even
bother like you know what I mean I just
wouldn't even I thought the CIA just
picks it yeah I just yeah that's I just
they thought they pull them like out of
a like a lotto machine well no that's
not true because my grandma has been
dead for about 18 years and she still
votes
vote and died
I'm going to torture you guys a little
bit and I'm going to make you watch a
little bit of the view
um I'm sorry but it's just fun for me
because again if I have to see it and I
have to suffer I want others to suffer
along with me so in in this particular
episode Joy Behar is talking about the
Republican party and that you know this
is going to be the end of the Republican
Party they're never going to win
elections anymore in this country which
I actually agree with because the game
is rigged so when the game is rigged of
course you can't win another election
but she says that uh the GOP is
responsible for
um school shootings and also tornadoes
apparently watch
they've said it all but this is the
beginning of the end of the Republican
party as I say it I don't see that
they're going to win in any elections
anymore in this country not national
elections they're on the wrong side
these kids were born in
1997 not 1897 which is where the
Republican party is going
crazy
I don't want to get killed in school I
don't want to you know be in the middle
of another tornado or whatever the hell
is going on in this country all I hear
about are tornadoes all the time is that
climate change
you know and they don't want all these
they don't want it they want they want
their abortion rights just in case
um she's a tornado she's a tornado I
can't I'm sorry but I'm confused we need
abortion rights in case we're going to
be the victim of tornadoes I don't
understand
the tornadoes dummy babies are gonna get
sucked up and they're gonna fling around
is that what you want I guess I don't
want that I'd rather the baby kill them
trained to Romans are an everyday thing
it's nothing to worry about but I
haven't seen a tornado before 2019. yeah
that's so perplexing to me that like you
heard all of the other cast members it's
climate change right they're like yeah
yeah yeah it's like you guys don't
remember tornadoes existing for like
literally
all time I'm sorry I just the levels are
stupid I mean the stupid people they're
always the most sure themselves and the
view is the perfect contrarian I had to
be contrarian time to put on the tinfoil
hat there is a technology called cloud
seeding in China they do this under
important politicians weddings they
might not want their wedding to have
rain on it so there is ways that the
military or the government can modify
the weather now can they create
tornadoes no but maybe Joy Behar if
she's probably in the Illuminati drinks
the blood of children maybe she knows
something we don't maybe they are not an
Illuminati they would not no there's
certain people that get in shoes
Illuminati Whoopi's in Whoopi Goldberg's
in the Illuminati yeah I mean obviously
yeah so you're in Louisiana obviously
you're in immediately no but these
people they we watch a few Clips all the
time because we have to when we get mad
and we know we're going to get mad but
we cannot help ourselves because you're
so stupid and they're so sure of
themselves but they go this has to be
tornadoes and kids the truth of the
matter is is that I mean I talked to a
you know you you our fan base skews
younger because of our show and there's
a lot of Zoomers that send us messages
and they're a lot more based than you
think the problem is you can't see it
because you're not allowed to be quiet
yeah we get like messages all the time
like don't worry man you're like all
right there's some cool kids out there
they're just doing like I can't say
anything in school because they're just
gonna crucify me well usually it used to
be a big deal to be a closet homosexual
now it's a big deal to be a closet
conservative oh yeah that's the new
closeted thing it's it's okay to be
homosexual just you can't be
conservative yeah um all right I want to
switch to Disney
um so I'm actually very upset about this
Disney is now altering the lyrics in two
songs in this upcoming remake of The
Little Mermaid so
um of course the the song Kiss the Girl
overall well they have to change that
because they're the man is forcing
himself on that poor mermaid woman well
the thing is I think the biggest problem
is first off you have to ask her
pronouns you can't say kiss the girl how
do you that's true with that and
secondly the consent thing is super fun
because you know you're romantic you're
working on heavy with a girl and you're
and then you always want to be like
excuse me before we continue may I
please kiss the lady
yeah can I kiss you yeah why did you say
that now you why you couldn't beat it
just do the Leaning and if they do that
you're like okay
for a long time ladies this is nothing
new we understand if you're we get it
hey got it my bad I messed up and you
move on with your life right but now
you're going to be on a boat with a
mermaid person by the way the most
important thing in this thing was a
mermaid person became a mermaid became a
person and then lost her voice the most
important thing is the consent in the
song We're in a fantasy world why do we
try to keep adding real horse summon the
fantasy world she's friends with a fish
and some some reason a Jamaican crab
come on enough stop it's a cartoon
you know I feel bad for young men who
are growing up now because it's like how
do you how do you date like how do you
date that's a topic I bang on about a
lot because like don't envy young dudes
now yeah it's just it's not a lot of
depth on that bench out there you know
what I mean it's a Minefield it's a
Minefield it really is so superficial
with the dating apps it's very hard
dating is basically just like Sideshow
Bob from The Simpsons just stepping up
to rake after rake just one after the
other on your face yeah that's dating it
fascinating history but then if but if
you say if you call your friend
then all of a sudden you broke a
cardinal rule and you go to jail and
it's like I'm just joking like they they
it's crazy because they they ban they've
been they've they were the ones who
banned everything when I grew up it was
you know the the family councils they
were Banning music and banning that and
nobody was on their side now they're the
ones Banning everything yeah and then
they go hey maybe we just shouldn't have
pornography and screens it's like really
okay excuse me oh now you're the word
police what if we want to show little
kids penis is in books why can't we then
they turn into Ron Paul Libertarians
immediately and they're like oh Freedom
foreign
we covered a story a while back where it
was like a kindergarten teacher and they
passed the bill he's like I don't know
man it's just like I don't understand
how after like a romantic paddle
boarding with my boyfriend over the
weekend I'll come in I don't understand
if my kids ask like how my weekend was I
can't talk about my gay paddle boarding
I remember I'm like it takes a lot of
shoehorning fruit to get a
kindergartener to like segue into that
for you I have a feeling it's not the
kids going like how was your gay paddle
boarding this weekend it's them going so
we're learning math today it's like yeah
I'm just a little tired from the weekend
though you know and they're like okay so
we're gonna do math yeah yeah a lot of
gay paddle boarding and it's like I
don't care I need to learn math like I'm
not gonna graduate but no truly the
crazy the craziest part is like more
people stood up for like getting common
car out of school than getting like you
know the groomers out of school it's
crazy so hear me out let's ban common
horror math I like that that's the bet
see you mix it together horror man yes I
was thinking I have a solution for
school shootings that if we actually
made our Public Schools under Sharia law
and we made it so women couldn't go to
school there'd be 50 less targets so
that would could reduce it by 50 well
there's a girl really need to go to
school just say give all kids guns